well again I see that it's a consequence
of continual agitation by I would say a
minority of of the left of radical left
in particular and those are people who
aren't Marxist / neo-marxist in their
fundamental ideological orientation and
have joined that in an unholy union with
the worst of French post-modernism and
and there they push it forward
ideological certainty and the thing that
the thing that's really distressing
about that is that if you know anything
about the history of oppressed people
let's say much as I hate to engage in
that particular form of dialog under the
current conditions it's pretty obvious
that it's freedom of speeches is a
freedom that's particularly important
for people who don't have anything else
right it's if you're supporting freedom
of speech you're not supporting the
status quo I mean just think about let's
let's use the logic of the radical
leftists and assume that society is a
tyrannical hierarchy and the people at
the top have the upper hand in
everything including access to
communication
these people are not your friends
[Music]
you see you know that's that that and
mark my words
that's the sounds of the barbarians
pounding at the gates right
[Applause]
yeah that's all I'll tell you again that
use of inchoate what would you call it
inchoate sensation is the best
formulation of their argument and
there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you so keep that in mind it's not
amusing there's nothing to it there's
nothing for it the thing that's also
quite appalling is that there's no
evidence whatsoever that the people who
are conducting these protests know what
it is that they're protesting against
you know I was in
[Applause]
all right I was in the midst of a
discussion attempting to make the case
that its freedom of speech that's that
is what people who have nothing still
have right so if you look at the
tyrannical structure of our society
let's say the people at the top have
access to means of communication
everyone knows that it's the people at
the bottom who have the right to say
what they think however badly they say
it that enables them to get a toehold
into the system into and to make their
suffering known that's what freedom of
speech is for and so like what's the
protest against that and I'll tell you
you know that the radical neo-marxist
types they speak the language of power
and that's what they're speaking right
now and if you want to live in a world
where everyone speaks the language of
power then just let them do what they're
doing and see what happens I wouldn't
recommend it it's not a pretty road and
you're all in a position you're on a
situation in your life now where you
have to make decisions about the sorts
of things like is this the sort of
institution that you want this to be